[Rires]
bon tout le monde les gens vidéo de
mytho
ok d'accord donc
tout neuf d'accord il paraît qu'à
l'intérieur là
il y aurait un petit couteau donc on va
vérifier ça tout de suite
je vais en direct
alors on est dans la loge c'est l'heure
de la pause c'est une 10 c'est une 10 ok
je bois le barrer c'est une 10 mais je
tape
si elle dit mais mais mais mais mais
non elle est blonde moins de 18 ans
elle veut se marier avec moi hors de
question à l'église en plus non
est-ce que vous imaginez ce qu'on est en
train de vivre la
il y a un autre titre aussi qui me tient
à cœur et que j'adore j'adore j'adore ce
titre parce qu'il est vraiment très
festif c'est le titre qui s'appelle
Desperado en français desperados bien
sûr c'est un titre que j'ai travaillé
avec soolking où il y a beaucoup de
guitares où c'est un titre avec un BPM
de PMC un rythme assez rapide mais ce
sont il me régale quand je l'écoute j'ai
l'impression que le soleil il vient
directement parce que il est très festif
et il amène la bonne humeur la joie et
j'espère qu'il va vous plaire aussi
amusez-vous bien avec despera